♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
IT TURNS OUT THEY WERE ALL
LYING TO YOU.
HOST.
THE SELF-RIGHTEOUS OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION HACKS THE
CORRUPT FBI LEADERSHIP THERE
WAS NO SPYING ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
THAT'S WHAT THEY TOLD US
AGAIN AND AGAIN FOR OVER A
YEAR.
THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE STILL
TELLING US.
EVEN AS THEY SIMULTANEOUSLY
ADMIT THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED,
THAT'S WHAT THEY DID.
THAT'S HOW DUMB THEY THINK
YOU ARE, BY THE WAY.
THAT'S HOW MUCH CONTEMPT
THEY HAVE FOR YOU.
THEY DON'T EVEN BOTHER TO
MAKE RATIONALE ARGUMENTS.
THEY BARK LOUDER AND ASSUME
YOU WILL BELIEVE IT.
TODAY DISGRACED BUREAUCRAT
JIM COMEY CLAIMED THE FBI
DIDN'T REALLY SPY ON THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
THEY USED CONFIDENTIAL HUMAN
SOURCES WHICH IS BY THE WAY
FBI CALLS SPIES.
COMEY PUTS IT FACTS MATTER.
HILARIOUS.
BUT THEN COMEY TURNED
SERIOUS AS SERIOUS AS A BOO
FOOTBALL CAN, SPYING ON THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN, HE SAID WAS
TIGHTLY REGULATED AND
ESSENTIAL TO PROTECTING THE
COUNTRY.
COMEY WENT ON TO POINT OUT
THAT ASKING ANY QUESTIONS
ABOUT ANY OF THIS WILL,
QUOTE DO LASTING DAMAGE TO
AMERICA.
HEY, SIRS, SHUT UP AND OBEY.